Tổng thủ của quay nè, vừa đi bia dân sĩ cho biết đã dạ dạm vời tổng thủ mì đồ năng trăm để văn dạy pháp
tăng cường phòng không trước các đợt không kích giữ rồi từng á, hay bây nất chỉ của hợp năng cao năng lực bảo về bầu trời.
Đông thời thảo lận về hợp đắc sản xuất của phòng một sấm và độ từ chung.
Cô địa đàn kéo dạy khoảng 4 mi phút trong đó của quay nà cũng để nghĩ Mỹ cùng cấp thêm hệ thông phòng không
tổng thủ mùa xíc tương tạm dừng một số lâu của khi gần đầy khêm kia, bọn ai năng lực phòng thủ sẽ bị xí dạm.
Chúng khi được cho biết đăng đạm phản một phát triốt để hỗ trợ của quay nà về phem y, tổng thăm cấp két sẽ ra xuất lại horde nậu cố gốc của kí cho kia.
Chúng tôi muốn ngay ông Trump tích lộ đã có cuộc gọi đáng tất vọng với tổng thủng năng,
bần biệt của tín, ngay sở đó ngà mở nất tập kích bằng ua về lợn nhất kể tổng thủ mô dôn dập tấn công kia.
Ông Jalenc kỳ chỉ trích đầy là hành động có chú địch và khí khích.
Chúng tôi thấy thổng thống Joe Biden, Mỹ đã viện sợ phát triốt chủ quay nà,
sòng ông Trump tương chỉ trích việc cùng cấp của khi nãy mặt không nhận lợi lợi ek là mất hợp lý.